I've already released my r-tx 2080 super
review you like to call it that it's a
faster twenty eighteen sells for around
the same price and while I have my
issues with that card the Arctic's
twenty seventy super is something
different entirely and worth a dedicated
video because there's important things
to talk about we have more competition
in this space the ironic thing is that
because it's different it actually
becomes awfully similar to the original
architects twenty eighty
so let's chat
if you're rocking the Windows 10
operating system and haven't activated
your copy click the link below and
purchase an OEM license from s CD key
then click here here here and then here
paste your activation key and you'll
have a fully activated OS in seconds and
be sure to use my offer code as studio
for an 18 percent discount on your order
so here's what I'm getting at in a
nutshell the 20 80 super was a rehash 20
80 with a few extra active SM is
actually only two extra 128 more CUDA
cores 64 per SM and while I didn't
explicitly mention it in that video I
have no doubt that this was released
later as a result find a fabrication
process if yields are higher you can
afford to release a different scheme my
argument however was that this should
have been refined from the start and not
sold as a separate SKU a year later at
the expense of early adopters for the
same price the Titan RT X was released
only a couple of months after the 22 Ti
both rocking the t1 a to die mind you
but with the Titans fully unlocked to 72
SMS and 4608 CUDA cores if Nvidia could
figure out how to refine that process
from the start why did it take them a
year to boost yields for an inferior
ship maybe they said a preference I
don't know what was going on internally
but that's the question I have for them
I don't expect everyone to agree with
that thinking but the RT X 2070 super
boasts a total GPU upgrade from the t1 a
sixth out of the tu-104 die so it's a
different approach to an upgrade the
same died about the RT X 2080
and RT X 2080 super are using is now
also in the RT X 2070 super how much
more confusing can Nvidia make this so
this results in a 256 scoodle core bump
from the original 27 t a healthy boost
in TDP and a higher sustained base clock
along with a higher sustained boost
clock the three cards I'd like you to
focus on these charts for the 2070 2070
super and 2080 Super since we expect the
original 2080 to be phased out in time
and rightfully so the 2080 Super retails
for around the same price the two 2070
variants for custom gigabyte boards that
were sent to us for testing a few weeks
ago and remain cool even under load we
should expect the same for an AI D 2080
Super so this isn't necessarily apples
to apples as usual sound intensity is a
byproduct of thermals so hotter cards
should
in theory run louder you can find our
testbench detailed in the video
description we've mentioned it several
times these past few weeks so I won't
waste any time in this video performance
bumps for the 2070 super over the 2070
don't look all that appealing for some
of our synthetic loads same can be said
for the 2080 super over the 2080
regardless of the resolution but venture
into popular games and the cards begin
to flex their muscles the 2080 super
dominates the ring with a whole 8 FPS on
average higher than the 2070 super in
GTA 5 and that the x12 API and the lead
widen is a bit up top while the 2070
super struggles to distinguish itself
from its non super counterpart in ashes
of the singularity shadow of the Tomb
Raider though in the exact same API dx12
the more powerful cards run a bit closer
together and the 2070 super pulls away
quite handily from the 2070 and in
Witcher 3 we see a newly linear
relationship between skews a 10 FPS bump
on average from the 2070 to the super
another 10 from the super to the 2080
and seven from the 2080 to the other
super in fact most graphs on the
Internet look like this one you'd be
right to question any result that pitted
the 2070 super above the 2080
or say the 2070 above the 2070 Superbike
this is just common sense right I kind
of fall in place where you would expect
them to and this kind of stuff seems
repetitive at this point but I still see
value in showing you the graphs at least
a few of them to get the point across
the upgrades themselves aren't all that
substantial and I don't think Nvidia
intended them to be what I will say
instead is this my issues with the 2080
super don't translate to my issues with
the 2070 super in fact since it's very
likely the 2070 and 2070 super will be
sold simultaneously for a long time
online and in big-box stores if anything
this is just a chance for the end user
to be a bit more picky you have a bit
more choice granted it's all from the
same company which is why regurgitating
an internal competition is kind of it's
just a lackluster I think you may have
noticed no that I totally skipped over
in the 5700 NXT variants in this video
and that's because my conclusions about
the 2070 and 2070 super are being
heavily influenced by these two cards
and require a separate analysis
let's look back at shadow of the Tomb
Raider at dx12 title where at least an
hour testing the 5700 XT outperforms the
2070 but fall short of the super by 9
frames on average the super dip really
well here I'm not sure if that's just
the die change or maybe the memory
bandwidth or what I don't know but this
is after three runs piece actually I
think some of these were two runs a
piece if they're within like one or two
FPS on average we don't run it a third
time so right now you can buy the 5700
XT for 400 USD here's some pricing
context but it's a reference card that
runs loud and hot we assume companies
like power color and XFX release AIB
variants which we know they are or gain
a power color sample here soon for
dedicated video stay tuned for that and
we assume they're going to mark up these
cards just a bit because they have beefy
coolers let's say 450 but it runs
quieter runs cooler possibly overclocked
right that's where the dilemma comes in
because you can currently buy an RT X
2070 duke from msi for 449 just one card
out of the many being offered and you
can grab 90 bucks worth of games in the
process this makes a decision a lot more
difficult for the consumer which I
actually think is a good thing you
should struggle to choose the graphics
card that's how it's supposed to be it
means there's a healthy degree of
competition in the graphics card market
something we've been missing in the mid
to high-end range for a long time a long
long time what was the I mean the raid
on 7 I think was discontinued almost as
quickly as it came to market and apart
from that if you want to go even more
old-school we had the r9 theory Theory X
all right Nana those are some of the
more powerful cards from a few
generations ago we haven't seen really
anything like that on the high-end
market for maybe since and that's one of
the reasons why I think I'm okay with
the RIT X 27 be super launch
despite the weird shift in GPUs it's
just kind of a weird thing to do but
also retain the 70 naming scheme
original 20 70s were retailing in
upwards of 500 600 bucks at launch right
back in really well late 2018 but with
the launch of the super variant a few
weeks ago 2070 prices have dropped by a
whole 100 bucks in some cases it's
pretty awesome
I loved the 1070 Pascal was awesome
right it's just straight up I love that
card 400 bucks
I give us 92 TI performance a $600 value
and a lower TDP for a deep discount we
might not have the same value gains with
Turing due largely in part to Nvidia
sleep and the ray-tracing technology but
I'm not going to complain about 2070
performance for the price of a 1070 and
it's not as good of an upgrade as we saw
the last generation leap but it's still
a good upgrade for the price and that's
practically where I'm getting at here it
took a while but I feel a lot more
comfortable with recommending at 2070 at
this point probably not what you'd
expect out of a 20 70 super review but
I'm always gonna be straight with you
guys I was building a mid to high-end
system for 1440p life for a gaming the
2070 and 5700 XT would be the two cards
in my sights particularly AIB but he's
on their backs T's for obvious reasons
so then what about the Arctic's 2060 you
haven't even mentioned that card until
now Greg what are you doing well again
it's all about price for me and I don't
see the RFC X 2060 falling in price to
the extent I'm seeing the 2070 doing it
in fact according to PC part picker
trends the 2060 has gone up in price of
it following the 2060 supers launch
which is a bit confusing to me may have
something to do with inventory levels
I'm not sure I think the sweet spot for
that card though is around 300 to 350
bucks especially if you can already get
a 2070 for a little over $400 so if
you're seeing 20 60s or even 20 60
supers for 400 plus USD in my opinion
the 2070 is the better by assuming that
card is not selling for about boards of
$500 prices are all over the place right
now it's because nvidia is releasing you
so many different generations generation
so many different SKUs and at the same
time they're offering tons of different
cards all in the mid to high range
market and it can be overwhelming for
the consumer one of the reasons why I
wanted to give the 2070 super dedicated
review because I think it actually sheds
more light into how good a value the
r-tx
2017 on Super has become as of late but
I've got to fall back on my quote from
the last r-tx video if I had to choose
between all these cards for the best
value of the bunch I'll be honest it
isn't on this list I still think it's a
1660 and TI models I think those are the
best value cards we have dedicated
videos coming out for those in a few
weeks I know we're late but a lots been
happening here that we haven't talked
about yet so we'll catch up on that
stuff soon but I will say that the 20s
and 5700 XT looked to be decent
offerings right now from both green and
red teams and I'd be content on really
either for my next high-end 1440p game
angry I know there are some of you out
there who are gonna straight-up refuse
to buy anything with an Nvidia label on
it and that's fine I don't care it
doesn't affect me really at all
i it's it's actually why I encourage
competition right and we're seeing the
repercussions of that at least in the
mid-range graphics card market but AMD
still needs to get their act together in
the high-end apartment we desperately
need something to compete with the
twenty eighty and twenty BTI
the fact that a twenty two TI cost over
a thousand dollars still in 2019 to me
is a bit mind-boggling I have a feeling
we'll be waiting a while by the way for
anything viable from the red team to
come to market to compete with something
that expensive from Nvidia that's all
for this one thank you all for watching
this far if you liked it give it a
thumbs up I appreciate it click that red
subscribe button for more like this and
you click that Bell for redundancies
sake because who knows what's going on
with you two at any given moment I'll
catch you the next one this is science
video thanks for learning with us